it's like i'm pulling out beads on a
piece of string and as they're pulling
taut it's unraveling the knot which is
the story
if like me you're a child of the 80s
then you'll probably remember these
books fighting fantasy books written by
steve jackson and ian livingstone where
you get to choose your own route through
the book so this book isn't broken up
into pages but rather it's broken up
into paragraphs sections
and at the end of each section you get
to choose as always that turn to section
282. let's look at this section for a
moment right section 267 we're on our
adventure and we find ourselves at a
crossroads it's incredible how often in
these books you find yourself at a
crossroads and not surprisingly we can
go north south east or west and then we
have to choose which number we're going
to so it's not linear right it's not
like i'm going from the front of the
book to the back of the book i'm all
over the place ultimately what we end up
with are
battles where we find ourselves fighting
monsters as a player i have skill and
stamina and if my dice rolls are high
enough then i defeat the chieftain and i
win and if my dice rolls are too low
then i die in some grisly and
unfortunate way which is normally you
know painful i mean i credit these with
these with teaching reader reiki first
of all so so for me these are
a really pivotal moment in my life and
and
and so i brought my nephews the same
books when they got to the same age and
now they're reading them and i'm really
proud of that too but the thing about
this book is we can treat it not just as
a as a book but also as a as a graph
right now
i'm guessing to to most people when i
say graph people think of pie charts and
bar graphs but what i mean by a graph in
this case is a set of nodes or vertices
connected by lines to show you what
decisions you can make at each node and
we use graphs in maths for for
everything so we use graphs for showing
how data is connected and so when you're
writing computer software
you end up with
usually special cases of graphs like
trees
for eliminating data very quickly from
searches and so if you want to write a
search algorithm that's quick you need a
graph
or if you're
into road traffic management and you
want to know how best to flow traffic
around a town then you want to make a
graph of that town to show where all of
the roads are but what i want to do is i
want to make a graph of of the book this
book is the warlock of fire top mountain
now doesn't that just leap off the page
that's fantastic you have to start
somewhere so we'll start at number one
that's where these books always begin
with a little description of the
adventure you're about to have
and then at the end after a few yards
you arrive at a junction will you turn
west in which case turn to page 71 or
east in which case turned to 278 and we
make a choice and i'm going to
show you that choice on the graph so i'm
going to start down here just because
it's closest to me
with a node and it's number one we
either get to go out to another node at
or a node at
278. so now we immediately begin to see
that the book branches out at 71 we get
two choices turn to page 301
or turn to page 248 obviously with these
books you spend more times turning the
page than you do actually reading the
page 33 and suddenly we're being
attacked by an orc there's a very real
possibility that we might die here so
this could be the end of the story right
which would be you know pretty sad
because we've only made five decisions
to get to this point um in that case
you've got to go back to number one and
start again and probably make different
choices so it's clear that if i keep
doing this
first of all i'm very quickly going to
run out of paper but it's going to take
a really long time and i'm guessing that
you probably don't want to watch that so
what i've done is i've
written a little program which contains
every link lifted from this book so
every time you get to make a choice
i've i've noted down that choice
and i'm going to get the program
to draw out the graph and the way it's
going to do that is i'm going to start
with each node of the book distributed
uniformly on the page
and the ones that are linked together
they're going to feel an attractive
force like a gravitational force between
them pulling them together
and the ones which aren't linked
together they're going to feel the
repulsive force and so the anti-gravity
right so we're going to have to invent
anti-gravity at this point that's going
to let the computer form up the graph
almost organically for us here we go
there's my big repulsive force coming in
and showing us the choices that we've
made so i'm just going to zoom in on
this start point there it is
immediately we make two choices that's
what we saw and then we followed through
on those choices and we see the whole
maze just starting to unravel before us
by the time we get to this node right
here
let's just zoom in on that
every choice that we make
brings us to here now if i display the
numbers
and we find that whatever we do in this
story
if we want to progress
we have to get to number 214 and
eventually
we get here to this enormous maze let me
just turn off the numbers so we can see
it more clearly as a child i spent a lot
of time lost in this mace the maze of
the maze of zagat i always used to find
myself back at the same crossroads again
and again and again you might think that
this book's about going and killing the
warlock and stealing this treasure but
actually the point of all of these
fighting fantasy books
is to turn to section 400 and and that's
the end you know when you see turn to
section 400 you know you've finished
because that's always the last section
so this gives you sort of warm feeling
inside yeah i did it you know and and we
can see that right here we can see that
we make it through the maze of zago and
then we're back onto just like the start
a fairly linear path but eventually we
get to this gold piece
which is the magic number that's 400
okay so so i love that that's brilliant
what you will have noticed if you've
been paying attention is that
some of these spots are red i've gone
through the book with brady's help thank
you brady
um i've gone through the book and i've
made a note of every place you can die
and there's a couple of other points in
this book which i think are quite
interesting too and that's that this
node for example is black
okay now a black node is a situation
that you find yourself in which for me
was always the most depressing now let's
have a look this black node is 118 so
i'm going to look at section 118 in the
book now the first thing we notice about
this section and believe me i got very
good at noticing this when i was reading
these books there's no turn to we're not
going anywhere we've turned to this
section
and we've looked at the vampire and he's
killed us that's why when i start
turning my way through this book my
instinct was to leave my fingers in the
decisions that i've made previously
because then when i get to section 118
and i'm killed by the vampire oh you can
know that my first instinct just arrived
where was i then and straight back to
the previous section to make any other
choice that i can possibly make i can't
help but noticing a few little you might
have to zoom in on them for me one of
those bad boys down there down here we
find little clusters like this which
appear to be wholly unconnected to the
rest of the story
and if you don't know fire top mountain
intimately like i do and
then this isn't going to make any sense
to you
so look away now if you don't want to
know the answer right turn off no don't
turn off oh i know what we'll do if you
want to see what happens there click on
clicked on 400
we'll have a little click on 400. that's
great and we'll have a separate hidden
video where james explains what that is
hi there everyone just a quick message
to let you know
the idea for this film on numberphile
came from a conversation with a friend
of mine named sean who's making a
feature length documentary about the
guys who wrote these books you can see
some of the footage on the screen there
on the other side of me
and in fact you can see there one of the
actual maps used by the writers to
design their book rather than the
retrospective ones that we showed you
now shawn's film is to be called turn to
400 but to make it happen he's trying to
raise money through kickstarter so if
this is a topic that interests you and
you'd like to see this other film get
off the ground please go and support her
and i'll put a link underneath the video